E aí
[Música]
se você já pensou em suicídio
Tá bom acredito que eu comecei com uma
pergunta outro pesada demais vamos
trocar por enquanto você já pensou e
cuidar das pessoas através do que você
sabe fazer de melhor
e eu deixo sempre soube que o meu
propósito de vida era cuidar de pessoas
minha principal linguagem do amor é o
serviço eu demonstro carinho e afeto
através de ações como por exemplo
Comprar flores para minha mãe todas as
semanas às vezes e dizer que eu te amo
eu te amo para ela ou fazer um doce para
o meu pai porque ele sabe o quanto ele é
importante para mim
bom e como toda adolescente entre os
meus 17 e 18 anos eu tive que escolher o
que fazer para o resto da minha vida e
bom minhas opções não eram muitos dentro
deste conceito de cuidar de pessoas
medicina não era uma opção para mim
porque provavelmente eu desmaiei antes
de atender o paciente se aguentado
enfermagem - porque a minha memória é
péssima então eu provavelmente trocarem
os remédios dos pacientes e alguém não
sairia bem mesma história
o e de todas as áreas que envolviam
cuidar de pessoas da cidade sentir mais
normais assim que envolveu curar de
pessoas área que mais me sempre Me
interessou na época foi a da Psicologia
para mim parecia ser muito interessante
poder cuidar das pessoas através da fala
e do ouvir mas ainda assim não era o
suficiente para mim
e sempre que eu também entrei me ajudar
um pouco eu passava por um pequeno de
lema familiar onde
só porque vocês saibam na cidade onde eu
moro somos só eu meu pai e minha mãe
então nós somos uma família extremamente
unida a gente faz Praticamente tudo
junto
eu e o meu pai sempre foi a pessoa que
mais me incentivou dentro da área da
criatividade do Design da arte desde
pequena me levando nos museus e Galerias
e os shops sempre me gente vai andar
essa esse meu lado criativo
e como vocês podem imaginar ele fez
faculdade de design e fui boa vocês
podem estar pensando aqui hoje eu faço
design porque a fruta nunca é muito
longe do pé mas a realidade não foi
muito bem assim que aconteceu as coisas
né porque eu era um pouquinho Rebelde
então eu nunca que daria o gostinho para
o meu pai de continuar o sonho dele
dentro do Design e para me ajudar também
meu avô ele foi para o Retiro esta e ele
também mexer com essa área de criar
coisas
mas a realidade a querer que eu me
recusava se design também o design que
meu pai me apresentava que era muito
diferente do que eu conheço hoje
mas o que aconteceu foi que eu não
passei na faculdade de primeira tive que
tirar um pequeno nem sabática livra eu
tem que usar tudo de novo e tentar mais
uma vez e foi nesse nesse meio tempo em
que muitas coisas aconteceram e eu
comecei a ter novas dúvidas sobre o que
fazer para o resto da minha vida é
Olá você que aquele caminho Será que era
o certo será que era o que me faria
feliz eu faria com amor
bom e foi e foi nesse momento que eu
tive que me fazer a mesma pergunta que
eu fiz para vocês o começo não se eu já
tinha pensado em suicídio mas sim como
que eu poderia cuidar das pessoas com
que eu sei fazer de melhor
e eu desde sempre fui uma criança muito
curiosa sempre gostei de criar coisas de
experimentar coisas novas
e o design que me foi apresentado na
época era um design muito sobre coisas
legais e bonitas e muito mais sobre
estética do que exatamente cuidar de
pessoas
Ah mas tudo bem né também tem lado mas
foi em workshop que meu pai Insistiu
muito para que eu fosse em que eu ouvi
uma palestra sobre o que significava
design o que eu podia fazer com ele
entrar em muito diferente do que eu
conhecia o design que envolvia
transformar a vida das pessoas e também
poder dar significado e propósito as
coisas
E aí
é um design que para mim hoje é sobre
ser político ser social ser
transformador sem inclusivo da ele traz
à tona temas que muitas vezes a gente
nem imagina que exista e muitas vezes
revela problemas que a gente ignora
é um design que desperta muito mais do
que deseja e nós desperta a empatia e
despertar anos eu por Um Mundo Melhor
e hoje eu escolhi um caminho diferente
do convencional para cuidar das pessoas
assim eu descobri como eu poderia servir
e ajudar ela
e muitas vezes eu brinco hoje em dia e
falo que eu escolhi design porque o que
eu sei fazer mas não é bem assim que as
coisas funcionam na realidade que o
design ele me transborda e me incentiva
sempre a melhorar e me desafia também e
me faz enxergar o mundo de uma forma
totalmente diferente a cada nova
empreitada que eu lembro pelo design
e o que mais me tanto em mais me deixa
apaixonada cada vez mais essa licença
poética que a gente tem de poder
pesquisar em diversas áreas do
conhecimento e assim poder conectar e a
partir disso Inovar e criar coisas novas
dentro da minha área da área de outras
pessoas
e hoje eu posso pesquisar na área da
Psicologia posso pesquisar na área da
Medicina da engenharia da biologia da
sociologia porque o design é
extremamente multidisciplinar mas não só
o design a sua profissão também pode ser
extremamente multidisciplinar II ah
e hoje eu
cuido das pessoas ajuda as pessoas assim
e a pergunta que eu fiz para vocês no
começo se você Já pensaram em suicídio
não deveria ser um tabu ou ser
desconfortável para vocês
e nós vemos uma sociedade cada vez mais
é complicada e difícil que coloca a
gente sobre grandes expectativas e
pressão que são pessoas do nosso lado
que muitas vezes sem pensar coloco essas
expectativas na gente ou a própria
sociedade
É mas o que a gente mais precisa no
momento assim e momentos limites é de um
ouvido amigo para que a gente saiba aqui
nós não estamos sozinhos
e muitas vezes isso pode significar ao
entre a vida EA morte por algumas
pessoas porque são momentos assim de
desilusão em que nós simplesmente
cedemos
e o suicídio é considerado pelo
Ministério da Saúde como um problema de
saúde pública
tirando a vida de uma pessoa por hora no
Brasil no mesmo período de outras três
tentaram se matar
o e trata-se de um problema que na
maioria das vezes poderia ter sido
evitada
e o projeto fala ele é o mobiliário
urbano de prevenção ao suicídio que tem
como objetivo
aproximar e incentivar o diálogo e o
compartilhamento das pessoas ele também
potencializa a produção dos hormônios da
felicidade
e um deles é ocitocina que com certeza
minha favorita ele ela é o hormônio do
amor e do Carinho é através dela que a
gente consegue criar e manter os nossos
laços e a gente pode levar ela de forma
simples como dar um abraço em alguém um
beijo um presente ser generoso
Ah E também temos a endorfina que a
grande responsável pela minimização de
dor e estrés nosso corpo e a gente pode
liberar ela dançando cantando
socializando com outras pessoas
nós temos também a ser o Tolima que é a
substância responsável
pela nossa sessão de prazer e bem-estar
Oi e a falta dela o nosso corpo pode
levar a gente a depressão
o Edi também a gente pode levar ela de
forma simples como praticar um esporte
conversar com um amigo lembrar de
momentos bons
a impor último e não menos importante a
dopamina que a responsável pela nossa
motivação e confiança
a gente pode liberar ela dá pequenas
metas o nosso dia ou na nossa semana e
também comendo chocolate ou mas
principalmente
comemorando as nossas pequenas metas
batidas porque são nossas pequenas
conquistas essas pequenas coisas do
nosso dia a dia em que a gente encontra
o nosso caminho de volta à
E aí
G1
e o projeto ele aborda o assunto
suicídio de uma forma leve e abstrata
sendo assim ele ele traz o assunto de
forma de forma que faz com que as
pessoas ensino cada vez mais seguras e
também ao contrário do que muitos pensam
falar e discutir sobre o tema é o
caminho mais eficaz para a prevenção
assim as pessoas podem City a cada vez
mais acolhidas e também protegida senão
rejeitadas como se isso fosse algo ruim
é porque seu número sim que nós mais
precisamos de alguém do nosso lado
porque a gente sabe que nós não estamos
sozinhos
e o fala ele convida as pessoas a se
aproximar ele chama atenção de quem
passa sendo assim deixando as pessoas
escolherão que elas querem fazer e
também dando liberdade e convidando eles
a interagir da forma que eles acharem
certo ou como se sentirem confortáveis
é a forma dele é como a linha gravada de
uma sala
Oi e ele ele é todo retorcido ele é
feito de metal e por toda a sua
estrutura são gravadas frases de
perguntas que incentivam as pessoas a
terem ações que potencializam a produção
dos hormônios da felicidade
e
o fala ele serve para ser um ponto de
encontro o refrigério no dia de alguém e
um dia agitado e estressante
tá dando a possibilidade de todos podem
compartilhar E dialogar e abstrair um
pouco do que tem atormentado kadam
Oi e para mim o designer sobre isso como
nós podemos
transformar nossa sociedade uma
sociedade cada vez mais humana e
empática
e hoje eu cuido das pessoas como que eu
sei fazer de melhor no meu caso com o
design Mas e você o que você já faz de
melhor que pode trazer Impacto positivo
para a vida do seu próximo
muito obrigada
E aí